would do is keymon okay
I really come across
where
I keep my Center this way I step across
there it is same beginning but I step
across there it is in front of you boom
oh
he's gonna stay in the time so you
really want to right here you're on the
wrist already you already have up for
the rest you see and that stops his
wrist from turning around
that hits that leg in the box and then
this here stops him from
uh turning in here
[Music]
in dropping underneath
even even more
whoa
[Music]
it's kind of chill out there it is right
there
[Music]
thank you in that hole
this hole right here
with his body
[Music]
he's a virtually occupied okay
so you are taking this balance eyes
and then he counters that and that's
where your Shield will not get it
here she's twisting there it is right
there
[Music]
get the energy going
oh there's the twist right there that's
where I come in
okay
try it